وقال مدير مكتب الاعلام او المكتب
الاعلامي في الجانب السوري لمعبر باب
الهوى الحدودي بين سوريا وتركيا في
تصريحات للجزيره ان المعبره قد اغلق
نهائيا وبدون سابق انذار امام حركه
المدنيين وعمليات نقل الجرحى في الاثناء
وجهت فرق الدفاع المدني في بلده مليس بريف
ادلب نداءات استغاثه لمساعدتهم في رفع
الانقاض والبحث عن ناجي
المتطوعوه الدفاع المدني يطلقون نداءات
الصغاثه للعالم ليوجه لهم مساعدات تعينهم
على رفع الانقاض واخراج المدنيين من من او
العالقين من تحت الانقاب قبل قليل مدير
المكتب الاعلامي في معبر باب الهوى وفي
تصريحات الجزيره قال بان المعبر مغلق بشكل
كامل امام حركه المدنيين والجرحى
وامام الحركه التجاريه وانه لم يبلغ اي
جهه لم تبلغ المعبر بانها سوف تقدم اي
مساعدات انسانيه وبالتالي هذا يفسر الشعور
بالخذلان الذي لمسناه عند متطوعي الدفاع
المدني الذين ما زالوا يعملون لثلاثين
ساعه متواصله لاكثر من 30 ساعه متواصله
على اخراج العالقين تحت الانقاذ في هذا
المكان في البناء الذي يظهر الان في
الصوره كان مؤلفا من اربعه طوابق انهار
بشكل كامل فيه 24 شقه كما اخبرنا الناس
هنا
وقبل وعند الساعه السابعه من الصباح هذا
اليوم تمكن متطوع الدفاع المدني من اخراج
شاب على قيد الحياه وكان سليما بحال جيده
في هذه البلده اخرج اكثر من 30 شخص كما
روى لنا السكان هنا من تحت الانقاض
ولكن ما يزال العمل جاريا في موقعين هذا
الموقع وهناك مبنى اخر مدمر في هذه البلده
عمليات الحفر ما تزال مستمره وهي تتطلب
الكثير من الحذر كما يقول عناصر الدفاع
المدني لانها لان اي حركه خاطئه يمكن ان
تؤدي بحياه
الناجين اذا ما كان هناك مزيد من الناجين
تحت الانقاض في كل لحظه يتناقل الناس
الاخبار حول خروج اناس احياء من تحت
الانقاض بعد مرور اكثر من 30 ساعه هذا ما
الامل للناس الذين يقفون بجوار هذه المبنى
يمكن ان تتحرك الكاميرا اليهم
وهم يراقبون عن كثب ماذا يحدث وينتظرون
خبرا ما عن ذويهم الذين
ردمتهم الانقاض وياملون بان يكونوا ما
زالوا احياء